every superhero has its catchphrase and
the meaning behind Neymar's Battle Cry
has finally reached the surface warning
minor spoilers for the Black Panther
sequel just ahead
building on the foundation laid by its
predecessor black panther wakanda
forever flushes out the Marvel Universe
a little bit more by introducing yet
another new nation previously unknown to
the rest of the world talukan is an
underwater Kingdom populated by
remarkable people who could extract the
oxygen Out of Water making for a society
like nowhere else on Earth their ruler
is a fearsome cuckoo Khan otherwise
known as vintage Marvel Comics character
Neymar the Submariner as a leader Neymar
shares many similarities with the
various rulers of wakanda ultimately he
wants his people to remain safe which
for a long time is required keeping the
kingdom secret from the rest of the
world but whereas t'challa came around
to the notion of revealing some of
wakanda's Secrets by the end of the
first black panther Neymar has succeeded
in keeping talukana secrets for the most
part Namor is one of the more
interesting antagonists in a Marvel film
because much like Eric killmonger the
audience is able to understand where
he's coming from even if he does get up
to some pretty controversial stuff
Neymar has been translated except really
well from comic book pages to the big
screen this adaptation of the comics
also includes Neymar using his signature
catchphrase during the movie if you pay
close attention to the subtitles during
an important battle in Black Panther
wakanda forever you might notice that at
one point Neymar shouts out the Curious
line imperious Rex this is of course a
Latin phrase where Rex translates to
King while imperius means something akin
to Emperor or commander of the armies so
it kind of just means the commander King
which begs the question as to what
Neymar is even trying to convey in the
movie it's pretty much there because
it's Neymar's catchphrase from the
comics and he's not the only one who
uses it Neymar and other atlanteans
frequently shout this phrase before
heading into battle despite being
created in 1939 Neymar wouldn't start
saying imperious wrecks until the 1960s
when he was reintroduced in a Fantastic
Four comic and it stuck ever since
eventually making its way into the most
recent Marvel flick every great comic
book character needs a catchphrase the
thing has it's
well the Hulk has an incredibly similar
line of his own
as far as battle cries go those are both
pretty straightforward they mean exactly
what they say but Neymar's big line is
leaving plenty of people confused about
what they're supposed to feel whenever
he shouts it once in the comics Neymar
attempted to provide some clarification
about what he means by the big line
detailing his reasoning in 2018's Thor
issue 1. in that book Thor spends a
while duking it out with Neymar during
the battle Neymar unleashes his
signature catchphrase to which Thor
responds in a surprising way saying all
these years Namor and I still have no
idea what that even means ever the
friendly foe Neymar decides to shed some
light on the situation by explaining it
means I'm going to feed your sorry ass
Guardian High to the biggest sharks I
can find which isn't exactly accurate
still that explanation does a pretty
good job of capturing the essence of
what Neymar likely means whenever he
shouts his big line I've been saying it
for years and if you heard it that made
your ass
[Music]